c'est quand même la première seconde
aussi quand il ne la trouble ivanoh
demers photographe du journal la presse
est un reportage en haïti pour la
première fois de sa vie en janvier 2010
avec la journaliste chantal guy il
accompagne l'écrivain dany laferrière
qui revisite sa ville port au prince
j'ai faudrait a fait une pâle et le jour
avant le séisme
toutes les enquêteurs seulement les
portables condamné alors on a vraiment
fait un très long c'est très intéressant
ce sont les dernières photos avant la
catastrophe
ivano et à son hôtel en train de trier
ses photos il est 16 heures 53 le 12
janvier 2010 qu'elle ait craché aller
comme ça comme un bateau égyptien au
fond du couloir j'ai descendu litre hors
spirale d'escalier j'arrive à bord puis
lalafell ça commençait vraiment tout
tombait de partout instinctivement
l'afeji même sauté et dernière marche
j'allais vers la gauche et la droite
c'était fondre à côté les buildings à
tomber
il était temps que safin s'arrêter ça a
duré 35 selon plusieurs personnes
pensent que j'ai commencé à faire des
fautes immédiatement police
on n'est pas du tout la grande photo un
mode survie survie et entraide se
retourner pour chercher ma journalistes
qui étaient avec moi puis je voulais
avoir cet écart ex était vivante fait je
suis retombé à l'intérieur de mon hôtel
plomb surcroît zip le gie primé cameron
après a prêché jamais tombé dans ma
chambre le métro
[Musique]
en est en état de choc il y avait des
gens qui hurlaient par tous en scène
d'apocalypse
c'est une heure ou deux après le
tremblement terre seulement
voyez les gens ont gardé des barreaux de
chaise et garde ayant des droits
déchirent des doors un des gens locaux
en haut des tours et s tout le monde
travaille ensemble
le photographe a pu dire à ses collègues
de montréal qu'ils étaient vivants sur
place quelqu'un les retrouve quelqu'un
qui a une connexion internet que je suis
passé des victimes à photographes
professionnels comme ça il parvient à
envoyer ses premières photos elles se
retrouveront partout dans les plus
grands médias du monde
[Musique]
j'ai fait des photos je crois que
j'arrête pas fait j avais pas faire
partie de l'événement parce que étant
donné que j'étais victime moi aussi il y
avait des gens qui étaient mans des gens
qui pleurent et j'allais les voir
comment ça vous
évidemment la mort la mort les termes du
présent a été le début d'une couverture
qui est il
qui vont marquer je le reste à mes jours
et on comprend qu est en détresse
en janvier par roger blin
[Musique]
c'est juste qu'ils planes
j'étais superman pendant 3 15 jours j'ai
vraiment fait d'ériger plus des risques
je rentre partout je faisais vraiment
n'importe quoi le montana je suis monté
je suis grébé sur le mental qui étaient
des twists un triple puis j'avais pas la
ferme
mais si je dis ça me tente et je suis
monte au dessus que ma petite conne puis
mes photos je faisais n'importe quoi
avec un peu de recul un gars aujourd'hui
je suis j'ai été victime d'un choc post
traumatique une scène en particulier la
démolit cette chaîne fait la seule voie
qui est en détresse puis l'homme
malheureusement elle est morte devant
moi et j'ai fait souvent des morts dans
ma vie mais quelqu'un qui meurt devant
moi pendant que judas j'ai trouvé ça
très difficile j'ai arrêté de faire des
photos chalet dans le coin puis je me
suis recueilli pige pense que j'ai versé
des lampes en un petit bout du projet
j'ai remis mes caméras en place sur
construit ma journée
trois jours plus tard les photographes
venus de l'étranger commencent à arriver
ivan au crack balle est captée c'est
fini j'étais plus capable de rien faire
je peux dormir pendant trois jours à peu
près je faisais des photos des photos
des photos documentaires j'étais sur
l'adrénaline j'ai perdu vermand contrôle
total jetez plus capable de rien faire
j'ai pleuré pendant 2-3 jonathan après
sept journées et des années pour
surmonter son stress post traumatique
j'ai tremblé pendant la nuit suivante
peau de ce fait c'est un papa personne
était ta maison le soir là quatre ans
plus tard la femme sa blonde apprend
apprend la mer mais ça met le supportant
la main l'arête de tremblay m'a chaque
baril faty dit si je voudrais marquer à
vie l'entrée qu'est ce qui se passe avec
ça curieusement après c'est certain
quand j'ai réalisé que j'avais des
problèmes à régler chez consulter depuis
un an et demi qu'on y mange m'ont
vraiment aidé
je capable d'en parler c'est la première
chose que je me sens bien avec ça parce
que j'ai pas mal malheureusement il y en
a 250 mixant mort était très chaud c
depuis 2010 ivanhoé retourné cinq fois
en haïti les haïtiens ont besoin d'être
ils sont a su sont résilients et wii
sont victimes de problèmes comme tous
les autres pays autour de ces progrès
mais à la base la 7e place
il mérite le respect et il mérite d'être
écouté puis il me les ai aidés
évidemment aussi une fille ont besoin de
notre aide